Il faut pour le tout le monde fasse des
efforts je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
réforme injuste des retraites et jeudi
à françois hollande aura pas de
réforme injuste des retraites si on ne
fait pas un effort pour alignés et oui
pour aligner les régimes le privé le
public les régimes spéciaux les
parlementaires aussi pourquoi pas le
sujet en réalité c'est qu'on l'a
déjà fait
souvenez-vous
fait cotiser il est fonctionnaire de 37
ans et demi à carentan on a recommencé
pas aligner les régimes spéciaux
continuez dans ce sens et marisol
touraine a en réalité enterré
une réforme juste en disant qu'elle ne
toucherait pas mon régime des retraites
du secteur public nous sommes en direct
8 valérie pécresse gilles clerc
question c'est sur cette réforme qui
secoue aujourd'hui démarre la confiance
sociale
de quelle réforme des retraites du
gouvernement vous pourriez le produit il
faut que j'attende quoi
parce que la cdc c'est une réforme
importante pour le plan sans défense du
citoyen et pour le pays
est-ce qu'on pourrait sur cette question
la surmonter a plu clivages politiques
est-ce que vous pourriez voter d'abord
pour cent
m je veux dire à françois hollande
puisqu'il nouvelle conférence des
retraites je veux dire à françois
hollande pour que maintenant le rythme
décision et à l'action il faut assumer
la réforme il pas on a essayé de de
toujours être dans l'esquivé et et
dans le nouveau roman qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire
selon nous la réforme que nous
pourrions voter
selon moi il faut pas toucher
au pouvoir d'achat des retraites
pourquoi parce que c'est un pacte de
confiance qu'on a compris que les
retraités
il ne faut pas toucher non plus op
cotisations des actifs et des
entreprises parce que les actifs
ils vivent moins bien que leurs parents
et les entreprises sur leurs angoisses
leurs cotisations sociales elles ne
créeront pas d'emplois or le chômage
aujourd'hui c'est le fléau de la hâte
de la france donc ni baisse des
retraites ni hausse des cotisations ce
qu'il faut c'est allongée la cdu aurait
de cotisation et pour moi la bonne
solution ces deux pour retarder le
départ à l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite jusqu'à 65 ans à horizon
qui pourront y va au front